thank you so much for 10 million
subscribers and I have been racking my
brain trying to come up with a way to
say thank you again even though over the
past few weeks this has been nothing but
logs telling you guys thank you and I've
been debating of what I'm gonna do
should I do a montage should I go back
in time and look at my older videos
should I do some other silly stuff and
all yesterday I knew I was going to hit
10 million yesterday and all yesterday
all I wanted to do was work on now
because me I was a funny idea that I had
in my mind and I made me I'll came from
an idea that I put in yandere simulator
where I just put my lips over cat's
mouth and made it go meow and it made me
laugh really really hard like more than
it should have to see that happen so I
wanted to make a full video of it and
yesterday like I was just sitting in my
chair like oh man I know I have to make
something for 10 million but I really
want to work on this and so for 8 hours
straight
I was just cutting out my own lips and
putting it onto different cats and if
you spend 8 hours looking at your own
lips you start to hate your own lips and
all the funny of the video gets drained
away after the first few hours and then
you're sitting tediously going frame by
frame and cutting with a mouse not even
a stylus or a tablet or anything trying
to cut out my own lips over and over and
over again so when I got to the end of
it and when it was finally done I was so
exasperated and disappointed with what I
made because it made me laugh really
hard in the beginning then it started
get less funny then I got a little funny
again and then I got less funny so I
uploaded it and I shared it unlisted
with a couple friends mind and they all
said that they liked it so I was like ok
maybe it's still funny maybe some people
will find it funny
so I released it and I put it on
Facebook and it's just like it's it's
quickly becoming my most popular video
probably my most viral video I've ever
made since five minutes at Freddy's and
maybe even going to exceed that so it
was really validating to know that the
stupidity that I laugh at and the video
that I wanted to make
that entire time that I was supposed to
be doing a big 10 million subscriber
celebration was loved by you guys and
that is really it's really validating to
me because the whole experience of what
I do on YouTube and YouTube changed my
life a lot it is done a lot of things
for me it's made me rethink a lot of
things and especially past events have
made me you know very self reflective
but it was so cool to see that this
video that I I didn't want to admit that
it was my 10 million subscriber
milestone video I didn't actually want
to go out there and say just in case
people would be really upset but it was
so comforting to know that people
accepted it in huge droves and you guys
shared it all over the world and I had
like Spanish sites that were tweeting
about the video and saying huh who's
really really cool and it was so I don't
know it just made me happy like it made
me really really happy to know that
after 10 million subscribers and all the
good that we've done and everything that
we've accomplished and how far we've
come and knowing that a million was
amazing and a hundred thousand was
amazing and you know a thousand was
amazing to know that even after all this
time I can I can crap how the stupid
video open and it can be accepted
because like creativity comes from
within like I I didn't obviously sit
pondering for months at a time wondering
like what video should I do I know I'll
put my lips on a cat and it'll be the
video like it creativity comes from
within it and often people say that
creativity is channeled it's not created
and that's my brand creativity that's my
silly lobar way down brand of creativity
but it's mine and it's what my channel
is all about and so after 10 million
subscribers knowing that that still gets
out to people and that still resonate
with people is so
happiness making what's the word
comforting validating I have no idea but
it just makes me really really happy so
I don't know how to say thank you I said
thank you so much every single time we
hit a milestone I can't help but say
thank you endlessly but after coming out
of this break in this hiatus and after
coming out what happened and after
looking at my own life and what I want
to do and being back here and and that's
actually not editing for me right now
he's back in South Carolina and just
kind of being able to connect with
myself again and what I really wanted to
do when I started this channel is really
really comforting to know that after all
this time that I can still do that and
and I get to do this for a living and I
get to do this every day in my life is
the most fulfilling thing I could
possibly imagine so although I have no
new way of saying thank you I will just
tell you guys that I am more committed
than ever to making the stupidest videos
pops possible and you know I'm more
committed to ever than ever to making
sure that this community does the right
thing with the amount of people that we
have so at the end of it all thank you
guys so much for supporting me thank you
so much for 10 million subscribers thank
you everyone that has watched or enjoyed
one of my videos and thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye